Who are you I'm the man who can
give you the one thing you want
what's that time he will bring me what
I need we can help each other with that
a beacon you're sending a message
a message to where
yeah I can rewrite existence and
shatter timelines you're an Avenger
the thermal luminescence indicates they're older
than that by a lot but you've lost a lot of time
like me
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. Marvel just released the new
Ant-Man of the Wasp quantumania trailer and
during it Kang's time platform like the device
he's using to try and change the timelines and
Wing the kang Multiverse War looks just like
shang chi's ten rings of power in the glyphs
on Miss Marvel's bangle which itself has a
deep connection to the actual 10 Rings going
back a thousand years plus so obviously the 10
rings in Miss Marvel's bangle are connected to
Kang so I'll break it down how it's connected to
Kang's master plan his technology in Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos the movie
is meant to be the beginning of Marvel phase five
and it looks like it's going to be a banger they
want Kang to curb stomp The Avengers literally
and metaphorically just to show you how much of
a threat he is before Avengers 5. I'm sure he'll
make Thanos seem like a walk in the park this is
actually Kang using his power over time to kill
Thanos to show everyone what a badass he is but
during the trailer Kang forces Ant-Man to help
him steal something that will help him complete
his time platform from the comics they will allow
him to use the quantum realm Quantum energy to win
the Kang Multiverse War like the whole key is the
Quantum realm and Quantum energy the place that
looks like Kang's version of chronopolis like his
giant City here that houses his entire Army all
of his technology is actually the device itself
like they're living on his weapon basically and
Kang's going to use this like this particular
weapon that he's building this giant weapon
even though obviously they're really tiny inside
the quantum realm relatively it's a huge weapon
to control all of reality all timelines because
the quantum realm is connected to All Points in
all timelines in all universes is sort of like
a substrate that connects to everything like the
blood vessels of all of reality reaching out to
every universe that's why Kang wants to use it
kind of like the one ring of power in The Lord of
the Rings Universe one ring to rule them all talk
about Easter eggs for the 10 rings when you see
Ant-Man reaching towards the energy inside the
giant rings here it seems like the core of his
device is powered around this energy that looks
exactly like like the 10 rings of power energy
that glyphs on it look exactly at the glyphs on
Miss Marvel's bangles making it seem like Kang
is the person who created the 10 rings and both
of Miss Marvel's bangles they're supposed to
be two bangles according to the Miss Marvel
episodes we've only seen one so either there is
another bangle that was lost during history at
some point or the 10 Rings themselves are the
actual second bangle so where's the other one
I told you the British have probably looted this
place twice over by now then one will have to
do when Wong does his epic zoom in enhance and
they find the signal of the beacon inside the 10
Rings that's transmitting the energy looks just
like the gold energy that Ant-Man is reaching
towards here implying that the beacon is actually
transmitting to Kang who at the time that this
scene was happening this shang chi post credit
scene was still trapped in the quantum realm some
of Kang's symbols on his Rings also resemble some
of the symbols in the eternals movie the celestial
symbols me that Kang is probably using some Cosmic
technology like Cosmic Power Within his device
here so just turning the timeline the Marvel
phase four Marvel phase five movies when this
is happening the events of the shang chi movie
take place relatively soon after Avengers end game
like within the same year in the events of Ant-Man
and the Wasp quantumania are meant to take place
a couple of years after Avengers end game so when
the movie picks up I believe it's been about three
years since endgame they'll probably give an exact
time when they start doing more press for the
movie you also notice that when shang chi and his
father Wenwu are both wielding the 10 Rings the
Rings give off two different colors of energy the
gold color that you see that looks like the gold
color inside Kang's giant rings here in the same
blue energy that Kang is blasting Ant-Man with his
eyes glow with it as well making it seem like Kang
is coursing with Quantum energy like somehow he's
implemented it into his biology so it seems like
shang chi and wenwu are both wielding different
types of quantum energy when they're using the
10 Rings which would make sense if Kang is the
person who created them and you see basically like
a giant version of what's Happening Here down in
the quantum realm where Ant-Man is trying to stop
it from happening here's the cool thing too when
they said that the 10 rings are way older than
a thousand years like they're trying to figure
out where they came from how old are they actually
they're supposed to be ancient within the MCU same
thing with Miss Marvel's Bangles they're supposed
to be very very old because Kang probably created
them what probably happened is that he built them
while he was either in the quantum realm trapped
something happened like Kang's original time
ship crashed because it seems like they're in
the wreckage of a giant ship here and that's when
Kang was originally stranded in the Quan like he's
been trapped there for a long time during the
crash the ten rings in the bangle may have just
been blown into the normal Universe out of the
quantum realm like the 10 rings in the bangle are
the debris of his original crash in the quantum
realm and because the quantum realm was connected
to All Points in all timelines the place where
they exited the quantum realm just happened to
be in the past so the 10 rings in the bangle only
seem like they're ancient artifacts when really
they're from the distant future because Kang is
from the distant future it'd be like Iron Man and
Captain America leaving modern day Tech behind
during their Time Heist back in the 1970s also
side Theory too it's always possible because these
10 Rings look exactly like the actual 10 Rings
it's always possible that Ant-Man is the person
who's responsible for them crashing out of the
quantum realm and landing in Earth's past so like
a thousand years ago when Wu was walking along and
he finds the wreckage of the 10 Rings like oh what
are these weird Rings here why are they giving
off this weird Quantum looking energy because
the quantum realm is connected to all Points
in the timeline Ant-Man in the future could have
gotten into this fight with with kangan stopped it
blown this up and they just wound up exiting the
quantum realm in the past so it's always possible
that Ant-Man is the person responsible for when
we were actually getting the 10 rings I'm sure
there's going to be a bunch of casual fans going
in that don't totally understand how time travel
movies work like how is it possible for Ant-Man
in the future to be responsible for the Rings
winding up in the past but here's where we get to
Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty Secret Wars the ten rings
the Bangle sounds like they're going to be part
of how they're able to fight Kang because they'll
literally be using Kang's own technology against
him there's been a lot of rumors about how Marvel
is plotting out the transition between Avengers
Kang Dynasty Cliffhanger and then Avengers Secret
Wars because they kind of want to do the same
thing that they did during Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers end game where you have a downer
ending in Infinity war and then they wind up
winning the day like they wind up saving the world
the universe arguably during Avengers end game the
only difference with Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 is
we're talking about a Multiverse Saga so it's like
all universes they're trying to save there's been
a lot of rumors that what they're going to do is
they're going to have a very Thanos snap type of
moment at the end of Avengers 5 Kane Dynasty and
Kang will wind up defeating the new Avengers
like Anthony Mackey Falcon Captain America's
new Avengers that were meeting slowly over Marvel
phase 4 Marvel Phase 5 but then during Avengers
six Secret Wars the survivors will actually wind
up fighting another variant of Kang who's going
to be a version of the beyonder from the comics
like beyonder Kang the beyonder will be the person
to create battle world like one single world
for the entire all of reality the only thing
that's left but there's a bunch of survivors from
the Multiverse that are on that battle world just
like in the comics and Doctor Strange will pull
them together and create a Multiverse Avengers
team and they'll have like a massive version
of the final battle Avengers end game like
The Avengers Assemble moment but it'll be like a
giant Multiverse version of The Avengers with Fox
Marvel characters like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
fighting with Toby Maguire Spider-Man and so on
and so forth and I think with the 10 rings with
Miss Marvel's bangles it'll be kind of like a Thor
situation with infinity war and Avengers ending
game so during those movies Thor got a big Power
upgrade and he got Stormbreaker they wound up
recontextualizing the way that Thor's hammer
mjolnir works even though it's still very powerful
artifact like it still works in present day they
just redefined how the weapon actually works
what it actually does where the power comes
from it sounds like they'll wind up doing that
with the 10 rings in Miss Marvel's bangle during
Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 like oh you'll still
wind up using these like shang chi will still
use the 10 Rings after Avenger six Secret Wars
Miss Marvel will still use her bangle ages that
by that time they'll find very different ways more
powerful ways of using them I know there's a bunch
of questions about what's going on with Ant-Man
in his final of Fate during this movie because
obviously Ant-Man probably going to be a big part
of Avengers Secret Wars but who knows what's going
to happen during Avengers 5 Kane Dynasty so I
think part of the idea with this movie is they
want to make it seem like Ant-Man is sacrificing
himself like he says I didn't have to win when
Kang is trying to laugh at him like you thought
you could actually beat me that's hilarious and
he tells him in the trailer I didn't have to win I
just had to make sure that we both wind up losing
then he apologized is De Cassie as they cry out
and obviously the way they cut the trailer is
kind of misleading but it just sounds like Ant-Man
is going to wind up trying to fall on his sword
so to speak in order to kill Kang and prevent him
from escaping and it sounds like he won't totally
be successful because they want to make it seem
like Ant-Man dies and it sounds like he'll wind up
Surviving like they'll have some kind of moment
that will make it seem like he could possibly
survive like he won't be Perma dead he'll probably
just be trapped in the quantum realm again for a
while like he'll lose some more time so to speak
Cassie the Wasp the other characters will try to
spend the next couple of years after the movie
happens to try and rescue him from the quantum
realm again but also Kang will wind up Surviving
like whatever Ant-Man tries to do to him won't
be successful he'll survive escape the quantum
realm and then go on to the events of Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty now we do have Loki season 2 and it
does seem like that might be a version of Kang the
Conqueror because he's wearing the same costume
but the haircut is a little bit different so there
are a couple things that could be going on with
the version of Kang during Loki season 2. they
could either be saying that it's the same version
or they could just be saying that this Kang is a
completely different variant because they did
say that we would see a bunch of variants of
Kang in different Marvel movies in Marvel Disney
plus series and also there's ravana rensslayer
who's supposed to be Kang's love interest from the
comics so I do wonder if they're gonna reference
ravana or a version of ravana or one of her
variants during Ant-Man the Wasp quantumania
because one of the things they haven't done yet
like they've shown us how badass Kang is like he's
going to be really cool but they haven't explained
why he's doing what he's doing like why does he
want to control the timeline in all of reality why
does he care about winning the Kane Multiverse war
that much and it might have something to do with
a variant of ravonna renslayer I don't think that
she's featured during Ant-Man the Wasp Quantumania
but we will see her again during Loki season 2 the
version from season one you remember she escaped
at the end of Loki season one so that version
will be the one that shows up again during season
two we will get a new Loki season 2 trailer suits
we'll learn more about what's going on with Kang
during that series you can click here for my new
Loki season 2 trailer video and click here for my
full Ant-Man the Watts Quantumania trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!